hi this is presh talwalkar
in this video i'll teach you a shortcut
method to divide numbers by 19.
for example
what is the decimal expansion of 4 over
19
to figure it out we'll use a trick of
repeatedly dividing by two
to get the first decimal point we take
our numerator of four and we divide by
two
four divided by two is equal to two and
that means 2 is the first value of the
decimal
to get the next value in our decimal
expansion we take 2 divided by 2.
that gives us a result of 1.
so that means the next value in our
decimal expansion is 1.
we again use our trick we're going to
take our result of 1 and again divide it
by 2.
so 1 divided by 2 is equal to 0 but now
we have a slight complication where we
have a remainder of 1.
when we have a remainder we need to
slightly modify our procedure
we need to join the remainder with the
result to get the new value to divide by
so we take 1 and 0 to get the new value
of 10.
mathematically this is the same thing as
saying take 10 times the remainder and
add the result
so 10 times 1 is equal to 10 plus 0 is
equal to 10.
so to get the fourth spot in our decimal
expansion we're going to take 10 divided
by 2.
this is equal to 5 with the remainder of
0.
if you have a remainder of 0 you can
effectively ignore it because 10 times 0
is equal to 0.
so to get the next value in our decimal
expansion we take 5 divided by 2
which is equal to 2 with the remainder
of 1.
now we need to adjust the next value we
divide by we take our remainder of 1 put
on the digit 2 to get 12.
so we take 12 divided by 2 is equal to 6
and a remainder 0. we can repeat this
process to figure out more and more
spots of our decimal expansion
but what we figured out is that these
values of our results
2 1 0 5 2 and 6
this is the decimal expansion of 4 over
nineteen
point two one zero five two six and it's
pretty interesting that we can figure
out how to divide by nineteen just by
repeatedly dividing by two
you can check on your calculator this is
the correct result
i'm going to show you another example
let's say we want to divide 12 by 19.
we have this process of repeatedly
dividing by 2
and in order to make it a little easier
i'm going to write the result as
remainder result because the two-digit
number when we combine the remainder and
the result is the next value to divide
by
so to get started we take 12 divided by
two
this is going to be six with the
remainder of zero so i'm going to write
this as a remainder of zero and then six
so the new value we divide by is already
written as the two digit number is zero
six
so we take six divided by two
that's going to be a remainder of 0
and a result of 3.
so now you can see why we're writing it
this way the 0 3 becomes the next thing
we want to divide by
so we take 3 divided by 2 is 1 with the
remainder of 1.
this 1 with the remainder 1 becomes 11
11 divided by 2 is
5 with the remainder of 1.
now we can just read off that we want to
take 15 divided by 2
which will be 7 with the remainder of 1.
we can then read off we want to take 17
divided by 2 which is 8 with the
remainder 1.
so you can use the shorthand to figure
out the decimal expansion
of 12 over 19
we read off the second numbers this is
631578
and you can check on your calculator
this is in fact 12 divided by 19.
so it's a pretty neat trick if you want
to treat this video as a puzzle you can
try and figure out why this method works
or if you're curious you can keep
watching and i'm going to present a
proof of why this method
allows you to divide numbers by 19.
so here's the proof let's say we want to
take x divided by 19.
we'll assume x here is a whole number
but algebraically everything we're doing
here is going to hold even for any value
of x
so we can write x over 19 as x divided
by 20 minus 1.
we now divide
each spot we divide the numerator and
the denominator by 20.
so that becomes x over twenty divided by
one minus one over twenty now why did i
do this the reason is i wanted to make
the denominator
one minus one you know i want the
fraction one divided by one minus one
over 20
because
there's a special result that if you
have a geometric series with the common
ratio r
the sum of that infinite series is equal
to 1 divided by 1 minus r
so now i'm using it in reverse i'm going
to take
1 divided by 1 minus 2 1 over 20 and
expand that out so that we have the sum
of terms with a common ratio of 1 over
20.
so that means we're multiplying x over
20
by an infinite series that starts with
one and has a common ratio of one over
twenty
i'll distribute that
one over twenty so we have x multiplied
by an infinite series of one over twenty
with the common ratio of one over twenty
now what is twenty two you know twenty
is equal to two times ten so we can
split this out and saying to divide by
twenty
we could take that as two steps we can
divide it by two and then we could
divide it by ten
so here we have the expansion that we
want
if you look at each term in the
geometric series we're dividing by two
and then dividing by 10.
so the first term x over 2 divided by 10
that gives us the first value of our
decimal expansion
to get the next value we then take x
over 2
divided by 2 again which gives us x over
2 squared and then we need to divide
that by 10.
so that second term in our expansion is
going to give us the next value of the
decimal
so this is how we're repeatedly dividing
again by 2 to get the new decimal place
each decimal place is the value for the
next power of 10
and you can clearly see the numerators
in each time we're dividing by 2 again
now what happens if you have a remainder
well as you can see each term is going
to be one-tenth of the previous term so
if you have a remainder of
you know that's going to add 10 times to
the next fraction when you get a common
rate you know denominator you have to
multiply that remainder by 10 so you can
add it to the next fraction so this is
how we get the procedure
where we repeatedly divide by 2
is how we can figure out the decimal
expansion
for any number over 19.
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books this
trick about dividing by 19 is actually
included in my book the best mental math
tricks i've provided a link to that book
and all my books in the video
description